bonjour messieurs bonjour messieurs
vendeur mais si leur
eh bien nous ne sommes que trois
les autres sont [ __ ]
michel droit et couché puis du tour fait
le guignol ses couverts marguerite elle
a donné un petit mot d'excusés date ni
il est lui faute
c'est dommage qu'elle soit pas la
marguerite ce vrai boute-en-train de
l'électrique
notre ami mirepoix d'entités bien
qu'animée la petite sauterie cas suivi
les funérailles
c'est leur ego ils seront excités que
vous vers le bella une perf' tu me
soutiens cette news
messieurs l'ordre du jour mais qui sait
qu'ils deviennent les biscuits faits
c'est le jeune alain deux coups
il avait premier des boudoirs de marquer
beaucoup qui doit les goûters il vient
jamais ça fais pas çi cale bien
messieurs l'ordre du jour s'il vous
plaît le mois dernier nous avons inscrit
à notre dictionnaire le mot faux cols
dont vous nous rappeler la définition
cher confrère parce que moi je me sens
un peu faible astro avoir fait quatre
heures il faut qu'un l'escroquerie fort
répandue dans la corporation des
limonadiers les manadiers veut
d'ailleurs elle consiste à vendent à
prix d'or un verre de mousse en faisant
croire que c'est de la bière merci mon
cher nous avons un débattre aujourd'hui
de l'introduction gros dictionnaire
morpho que ce propos qu il y en à dire
vous faire un petit point 9 kgs des
boudoirs où il ne parlait pas de ce
jeune mâle appris qu'elle manque de tact
figurez-vous qu'il a envoyé des fleurs à
ma femme
o comme s'ils savaient pas vous étiez
pdc messieurs nous avons assez travaillé
propose de clore la séance comme la
nouvelle bonne m'attends à ce qu'ils
voient ça me permettrait de terminer ma
préface de mon dernier ouvrage qui
rassemble toutes mes préface rassurez
vous messieurs jeudi prochain c'est moi
qui ramènerait les petits gâteaux à bâle
je vais pouvoir mais attention à la
grève